un procès extrêmement attendu lundi
dernier julian assange a fait sa
première apparition publique depuis le
mois de février après avoir déclaré son
identité
l'australien de 49 ans a officiellement
déclaré qu'il ne consentait pas à son
extradition
une procédure que l'ensemble de ses
soutiens exclut également la force de
cette communauté et la force du système
judiciaire du royaume uni et la vigueur
de la frontière autour de la vie
nationale ici dépendront de la direction
que prendra cette affaire si julian ne
se fait pas extradé alors je suppose que
la force du royaume uni et de son
système judiciaire seront un exemple
pour le monde
mardi c'est une représentante d'une
organisation anti torture qui a été
appelé à la barre pour témoigner contre
des états unis un professeur en
journalisme a ensuite été auditionnés
ils étaient malmenés par le procureur
mais les avocats de la défense ont
finalement été stoppé le témoignage de
marc feldstein s'est préoccupé de la
surprise de l'acte d'accusation contre
julian c'est la première fois qu'un
éditeur est inculpé aspen enfin jeudi à
la surprise générale le procès assange
s'est fait rattraper par la situation
sanitaire actuelle en raison d'un cas
suspect de covile 19 l'audience a été
ajournée
avant la reprise du procès ce lundi
antoine veil un des avocats de julien
assange a signé une tribune dans le
journal du dimanche
pour lui cette affaire a dépassé le
cadre juridique il est clair que comme
toute accusation politique
l'incrimination fondée sur une loi de
1917 n'est ici qu'un prétexte
au fond ce qui est reproché à julian
assange c'est d'avoir mis à mal l'image
des états unis
et surtout de ses dirigeants tout bord
confondu la fere n'est plus juridique
mais politique
la règle de droit disparaît les
institutions que celle ci est censé
gouverner sont affranchis ce pour mettre
à terre celui qu'elle persécutent
ce procès devrait durer encore deux
semaines à minima pour rappel si julian
assange est extradé vers les états unis
il risque une peine deux cent soixante
quinze ans de prison